est ce que vous êtes agressif parce que
vous êtes petit pas non non non en quoi
je suis peut-être que si j'avais eu un
mètre 90 chevaux a été plus simple cela
dit c'est pas très crédible parce que
j'avais quand même 30 cm de plus que
vous dites moi philippe en mars 81 vous
avez poursuivi un journaliste de paris
est doux qui s'appelait jean michel
caradec parce qu'il avait écouté vos
conversations téléphoniques depuis votre
voiture et vous avez quand même demandé
trente mille francs de dommages et
intérêts oui à demander l'avis est
quelque chose à cacher non mais non
seulement il avait écouté ce que ce que
je disais dans mon radio téléphone mais
encore il avait publié dans un journal
qui d'ailleurs il n'a pas survécu arrête
mais d'autres raisons et j'ai trouvé que
bon le comme le je suis un téléphone au
magna qui clôt radio téléphone et dans
nos types de métiers et nos gens de vie
un instrument primordial ifec créer une
jurisprudence qui protège les usagers et
ça a été fait
c'était une conversation strictement
s'élever à mme c'était pas une aventure
même s'était injustement privé je
parlais d'un tas de copains bon il y en
a que je traitais bien d'autres que je
traitais moins bien et devoirs huit
jours plus tard c'est imprimé sa touche
au dans la journal ses magrets à bhl
pour les copains non plus le musée de
mariée depuis 37 ans oui est ce qui vous
arrive de céder à la tentation après 37
ans de mariage on bat de moins en moins
étant donné mon grand talent
vous avez bien que ça vous est jamais
arrivé de céder à la tentation on joue
le plus fort je tiens à rester dans les
limites d'une certaine ressemblance vu
déjà flashé sur une hôtesse de l'air qui
vous un sourire commercial vous avez
pris ça pour une avance vous les jeux il
ya une bonne histoire comme ça bon petit
thouars je crois que c'est dans un avion
d'une compagnie israélienne
l'hôtesse demande un passager il israël
bien son nom qu'elle comprend pas bien
son nom et lui dit vous mai aps les
égouts mais aussi est-ce qu'on peut
joueur ce soir oui bon